[SPEAKER_01]: And I was like, what should I do? So I shout out a little bit, hey! And then just turned the head. When he saw me, he was just diving down like a bomb
[SPEAKER_01]: and never seen again. So I think it was, this guy was scared at the moment. And I was also scared because I was so close. I was expecting that on a
[SPEAKER_01]: certain stage he said, sorry guys, today I don't fly. And that was it. He never flew again.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, every now and then we come across someone in our sport who just loves being in the air so much that they dedicate their lifetime for
[SPEAKER_00]: this. And today's guest is no different. I'm talking about the legendary hang gliding pilot from Austria called Manfred Rumer. More
[SPEAKER_00]: than three decades of flying all kinds of wings, fixed, collapsibles, flexibles. So join us as he sits down in the third installment of Risk vs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Reward as we explore the best possibilities to explore risk, the physiological and the psychological demands of flying, and how the
[SPEAKER_00]: sport has evolved over all this period of time to offer both greater rewards and new challenges. So tune in, as I'm sure this episode offers
[SPEAKER_00]: something for everyone who practices the art of flight in all its glory.
[SPEAKER_00]: Manfred Rumer, thank you so much for joining us. It's an absolute honor to have you on Paragliding Atlas. Oh, thank you. Thank you for the
[SPEAKER_01]: invitation. It's the first time that I'm in such a meeting or such a conversation. I like it already. Yeah, good. Thank you. That's so good
[SPEAKER_00]: to see. And it's an absolute pleasure having you just before the Coupé Car. How does your days look like these days? I think they must be super
[SPEAKER_00]: hectic with all the preparations for the Expo and everything that's coming up. Yeah, we're here in Icaro because we have a stand there with
[SPEAKER_01]: the helmets. Of course, the girls, they are in charge of that business. They are quite busy. And of course, I think everything will be ready in
[SPEAKER_01]: time. And for me, I will be there with the Swift again. This is my new Swift from this year to do some flight demonstration in the afternoon. I think
[SPEAKER_01]: it's Saturday and Sunday in the afternoon with the hang gliding. There's like... It's like a window where we can demonstrate our
[SPEAKER_01]: gliders. And some possibilities, yes. That's very cool to hear. And for the perspective of our audiences, Manfred has been working with Icaro
[SPEAKER_00]: and is a hang gliding pioneer. Three decades in the out of flight with fixed wings and collapsible wings. Manfred, just a little bit of your
[SPEAKER_00]: introduction for those people who are only paragliders, because since this is mostly a paragliders audience, who are you and how did you manage
[SPEAKER_00]: to get, how did you manage to touch the sky with glory all this while for so long? Yeah, okay, I'm Manfred Rohmer. I'm nearly 60 years old, 59 this
[SPEAKER_01]: year. Shit. Time is bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when I was a young boy, I was interested in, I don't know, probably my mother was folding some paper planes, very basic. So I started playing
[SPEAKER_01]: with that. That's how I got into aero model, model RC model, later RC model. But I was pretty much designing indoor models. They were flying
[SPEAKER_01]: like real planes with profile and so on like that. But really, I got fascinated. And then later, of course, with some RC models. And then I
[SPEAKER_01]: started hang gliding in 86. And from there on, it was like, that's cool. That's really good. And 86 was also the birth of paragliding. So that
[SPEAKER_01]: year when I started hang gliding, there was no real paraglider. So just some years later, they came along. Because I started in Austria, upper
[SPEAKER_01]: Austria, on the north side of the Alps. So it was more hilly area. not that big mountains so the first paragliders they didn't perform well in that
[SPEAKER_01]: area just later let's say 88 89 90 they got there doing better and better and yeah i think i was already i think 87 i started small competition 88
[SPEAKER_01]: the first austrian championship which i got through it I don't know how I did that, but I was like, oh, that's not that difficult. So in 1989, I was
[SPEAKER_01]: in the first world championship in Fiersch. And from there on, every year competing, every year going to competition until 2000 when I
[SPEAKER_01]: stopped with class one flag swing competitions. And then I came back again and then yes and no. But it was also 2002 when I started first flying
[SPEAKER_01]: the class two gliders, the Swift, which was always fascinating to me, the technology and the possibilities. And that's how I ended up now
[SPEAKER_01]: flying also the latest generation of the Swift. I think just the fact that you're nearly 60, which is, you look much younger, just to let you
[SPEAKER_00]: know. And you're still demonstrating at an expo like Coupé Car. It's so inspiring to see that, Manfred. And I hope a lot of us listeners who
[SPEAKER_00]: aspire to reach that stage can. But the first thing that comes to my mind is consistency. How did you do this, Manfred? Or let's say you were
[SPEAKER_00]: fascinated with the art of flight when you were very young. There's something about folding paper planes that excites all of us. Your own
[SPEAKER_00]: creation, when it glides. Even today, I have a bunch of paper planes sitting right on my shelf in the left-hand corner here, which I just, you
[SPEAKER_00]: know, whenever I find a piece of paper, I just fold it into a plane. It's very instinctive. I got oval already about this stage here. LAUGHTER
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because you're flying better than better. When my son was younger, of course, I teach them. And he was like in the kindergarten. He
[SPEAKER_01]: was throwing paper planes also there. And he was like the teachers there, the big ones. They said, what this guy is doing there always.
[SPEAKER_01]: After the education in free time, he was just throwing paper planes. And also he hooked up the other young kids. So that was, I think it's good to
[SPEAKER_01]: put kids into the direction just with the game, with playing and having fun and also learning what's important, why these things are flying. So
[SPEAKER_01]: the very basic, it's a good thing to start. Now, I agree. And I think the fascination is very infectious. And that's why this whole audience and
[SPEAKER_00]: us who are chasing the art of free flight are here today. But as I was saying, starting from the beginning of your time until now, you have
[SPEAKER_00]: pioneered and you have made your dream come true, which all of us manifest a lot of times. Usually, how have you, if you have to focus back
[SPEAKER_00]: and look at your motivation levels or making it happen or realizing all of this, what has been the key factor in you actually succeeding to live a
[SPEAKER_00]: lifestyle like this over the past, let's say, 50 years or 40 years when you actually started living life on your own terms? Yeah, I think when I
[SPEAKER_01]: started hang gliding, it was just a fascination to get in the air. I think it's generally free flying, like paragliding, hang gliding, you don't
[SPEAKER_01]: need much technology. Now it's really, there's also quite a lot of technology involved to make them good and safe and whatever. But with
[SPEAKER_01]: little money, you put your body in the air. And that's the fascinating thing. The first flights, And then, of course, when you do some a little
[SPEAKER_01]: bit longer flight soaring, starting thermaling and having that possibilities. And then especially when there are some friends
[SPEAKER_01]: around, you can share that experience. And so you can push each other pushes a little, you know. And then, of course, I started competing
[SPEAKER_01]: quite early. And before I started really cross-country flying, I started competing. So I learned cross-country flying in the
[SPEAKER_01]: competitions. I enjoy flying cross-country by my own. But for a long time, I was just competing. You can match one to the other in pretty much
[SPEAKER_01]: the same condition. And then you learn a lot. You learn big things. That's the thing which I really like in competition. But you also have to
[SPEAKER_01]: be the competition guy. You have to be motivated. Because if people are going, yes, I want to compete, but I don't really want. But that's the
[SPEAKER_01]: wrong thing. So you really have to. I traveled a lot in the world at the end. So I have seen many places which I never would have seen when I just
[SPEAKER_01]: fly my home base. So that's the nice thing also. So yeah, that was good times, especially at the beginning. But of course, beginning is a
[SPEAKER_01]: little bit, you have to learn. You have to be also a little bit careful not to over-push it, taking too much risk because your experience is not
[SPEAKER_01]: that high. You think, oh, that's easy. But then you sometimes get into a situation where later you can say, yeah, I was a little bit lucky and that
[SPEAKER_01]: could have been gone also quite bad. like some outlanding places or whatever, or some situations in the air, like when there are many people
[SPEAKER_01]: flying together, especially at the start. For me, the collision is a big thing. So be careful. You have to learn about it. Indeed. And I think
[SPEAKER_00]: you've touched upon a very important point over here that is like being careful in the beginning of your career. So let's say when you go out
[SPEAKER_00]: there, the fascination of flying itself is very overwhelming for all of us. But fascination of flying with 100 other humans in a gaggle or in a
[SPEAKER_00]: thermal is wow. That's a whole different feeling. You're in a whole different... If you're on top of that gaggle, it's nice. But if you're in
[SPEAKER_01]: between, like in the boar, it's not so much fun.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's amazing. It's really fascinating. Yeah, the view from above is magical to look at. And I think this is where we can start with the topic
[SPEAKER_00]: where it's as a beginner, the fascination, the pull to be there is very strong. But it comes with a certain bit of risk. And it comes, as you
[SPEAKER_00]: mentioned, you're out there competing with some of the best and some of the ones who are not so motivated, but still want to be there. So there's
[SPEAKER_00]: all kinds of dynamics going around in that era. How do you usually make your decision-making when your experience is not so much? Because the
[SPEAKER_00]: pull, the motivation has gotten you there somehow. You've made your resources count, you've put in the money, you've bought the equipment,
[SPEAKER_00]: you've trained enough to be there. At the same time, you do not have the experience to make all the right decisions according to the best ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: So how can a beginner navigate such a thing while still keeping the motivation and being relevant in the competition and in its own mind? I
[SPEAKER_01]: think, as you said already, that they're trained already. It's important before joining competition that you have done already a lot
[SPEAKER_01]: of flights. You're confident. Your technique has to be good. Take off, thermal flying, especially landing in small places. So that's the
[SPEAKER_01]: basic thing of what is needed for competition. You have to know. Like with hang glider, the thing, the outlanding is not that easy in small
[SPEAKER_01]: fields. So you have to know the technique, like with the traction, how you use it. To get really in small fields, that helps a lot. And then, of
[SPEAKER_01]: course, to go to competition is to learn, to see what's going on. It's a learning process. Some people learn fast. Some people take a little bit
[SPEAKER_01]: longer. But I never went to competition. And right from the beginning, I was like, One day I want to be a world champion. That was never the goal. It
[SPEAKER_01]: was so far away. I was thinking, if I get to reach a regional champion, that would be great. Just the little steps by steps. Then you reach that
[SPEAKER_01]: and then, then. Because I got very quick in the national team. That was also like, because I'm, let's say I, I learned quick. I learned, I was
[SPEAKER_01]: motivated. The motivation is important. Of course. So that's why I stepped up quite quick to end up in the, but also like the world, the first
[SPEAKER_01]: world championship, I had some good days and some bad days. And of course I was learning that time. I was learning a lot. And so later I progressed
[SPEAKER_01]: better, quicker and had better constant results to end up in top position. Yeah, I think that that does sum it up a lot. But there's one big
[SPEAKER_00]: dilemma that personally comes to me as well. And a lot of times I've asked this to my guests who are there on the show. It's like defining the sweet
[SPEAKER_00]: spot, identifying that line between irrational fear that is holding back your progress. Taking acceptable risk where you know that, all
[SPEAKER_00]: right, I can push this, but still safely. How do you try and identify that? Gut feeling is one of the answers that I get a lot of times. But
[SPEAKER_00]: again, unless you push outside your comfort zone, it's very hard to define how much you can trust on your gut. So irrational fear versus
[SPEAKER_00]: acceptable risk. What is your take on this after spending more than three decades in the air at the top level? Yeah, I don't know how to say
[SPEAKER_01]: that. It's... The thing is, what we really have to know is we should not take risks that we get hurt and then you cannot fly the next day. So I was
[SPEAKER_01]: lucky always if I had a bad landing or a little accident, I always could fly the next day. The worst was I twisted the leg, but the next day was the
[SPEAKER_01]: last day of the competition. So I was jumping off the hill and that was okay. But then I had to stop a little while. That's one thing. And the
[SPEAKER_01]: other thing is, of course, we fly paragliders and hang gliders, which are a great machine in the right conditions. But they have their limit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the limit is, let's say, it's the machine itself, but also the pilot. Like in paragliding, hang gliding, certain situations, you have to
[SPEAKER_01]: react the right way. That's an important thing to know and to train. and how to react, especially in paragliding. They are stable, they are
[SPEAKER_01]: open, they are good. I did also paragliding for two years. for a long time ago. And I was nearly jumping in the competition scene as well. I had the
[SPEAKER_01]: possibility. But at the end, I was so much in hang gliding, so I did not do that step. I was thinking I should have done that, maybe yes and no. But at
[SPEAKER_01]: the end, I never did it. So maybe it was a pity I could have done it. But anyway, there's a certain risk of the machine itself. And the other one
[SPEAKER_01]: is the pilot. And of course, the pilot takes the decisions But sometimes it's like the course is this direction and there's a bad part,
[SPEAKER_01]: especially in the Alps, let's say like this, when there are well winds and that creates more turbulence on some places where you have to go and
[SPEAKER_01]: you have to climb. And sometimes it's bad when you are there in this situation. You think, holy shit, what I'm doing, really bad
[SPEAKER_01]: turbulences and bad experience. But then when you go ahead, you complete the course, after landing, it's nearly gone. You say, okay,
[SPEAKER_01]: that was not nice, but... No problem. So that happens from time to time. So we are quite good in just putting aside this negative experience
[SPEAKER_01]: during a flight. And a lot of this is just head work. It's what's in your mind. It's really the psychological part. It really can put you down. Or
[SPEAKER_01]: you just say, okay, that was... If you find a reason why it was so bad or it was nearly accident or whatever, we always, when we go in the air, we take
[SPEAKER_01]: certain risk. Of course, if the air is calm and the conditions are nice, the risk is very high. The risk gets higher and higher when we fly in more
[SPEAKER_01]: extreme conditions. Then there, it's for some people, it's the limit over the limit. And for some people, it's still okay. But I... During
[SPEAKER_01]: competition, I was always even Over the time, we learned, like in this condition, we should not fly. So we canceled the day, even if it, like
[SPEAKER_01]: now, the safety standards or the safety precaution is, yeah, maybe for half of the field, it's okay. But for the other half of the field, it's not
[SPEAKER_01]: okay. So then we cancel and then we go free flying. And still, it's quite okay. So that's a good thing, not to push meteorological limits,
[SPEAKER_01]: especially wind speeds in some areas can be really a problem. Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty much. I don't know. The important thing is you don't
[SPEAKER_01]: have to get hurt. You don't have to hurt yourself because the ground is hard. It's not forgiving. It's bad. And there are too many or quite a lot
[SPEAKER_01]: of accidents that should not happen. Probably people could have avoided, but then it's too late. Yeah. broken hand or whatever. Got it. I
[SPEAKER_00]: think you've covered a lot of topics in here that I was coming to, but eventually if I have to sum it up, it's basically the flight envelope of
[SPEAKER_00]: the aircraft, like what conditions can the aircraft fly in? Is it able to handle this way, these kinds of winds and gusts or whatever is being
[SPEAKER_00]: forecasted and the flight envelope of the pilot, like how much trust and ability does the pilot have to handle that aircraft? Again, all of these
[SPEAKER_00]: are relative depending upon people, how they look at it. But what I do eventually understand is that there are some things which are black and
[SPEAKER_00]: white, such as forecasting. In competitions, there are organizers which are doing the decision-making for you. Free flight, of course,
[SPEAKER_00]: you can do that with a fair bit of background research. You can make a very wise decision on forecasting and not push the limit in that one. But what
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm wondering is people trying to push the limits and becoming a better version of themselves, can they possibly set up some safety protocols
[SPEAKER_00]: which they can try and stick with for longevity of career, longevity of competing span and all of that? Because technology, let's say, all
[SPEAKER_00]: right, you want to fly a safer wing, go ahead, buy an A glider or a mid-B glider or a two-liner, whatever your threshold is, depending upon
[SPEAKER_00]: that. Equipment, like harness equipment, you want to make sure that you're not so good at landings. Instead of going in for the paper-thin,
[SPEAKER_00]: super lightweight harness, you can go for something with a bit of a back protection, which takes care of you. But when it comes to designing all
[SPEAKER_00]: of these things, have you, over a period of time, set some goals for you that, all right, this is my comfort zone. I'm not going to push it until I
[SPEAKER_00]: actually succeed in becoming very comfortable in that one. And then I will explore outside this envelope that I've created for myself. Yeah,
[SPEAKER_01]: I can. In this case, of course, I can only talk about hang gliding. I had the luck or the possibility to come to a manufacturer, EcoRoad, this
[SPEAKER_01]: time for more than 30 years now. And I had the possibility to bring my own ideas and the design and to optimize the glide. And also I had to quickly
[SPEAKER_01]: understand what makes a glider safe and not safe anymore. Still, let's say with the hang glider, every certified glider, let's say even the
[SPEAKER_01]: safest glider, which I don't know which glider should it be. It's possible to go up, make a whip stall, push out and you can tumble
[SPEAKER_01]: everywhere. even with the bad certification rules. So that's a system problem of the wing and the low CG and the CG you can move so much because
[SPEAKER_01]: it's bedshift control, which is easy, nice to fly and it's fun, but there's some limits. And there's the other limit, which in the design
[SPEAKER_01]: you can... you have to understand how it works but let's say a swept wing like a hang glider with that kind of profile that has a certain negative
[SPEAKER_01]: momentum of the profile itself it needs then with full tide which she a minimum of twist to to compensate that let's say negative moment
[SPEAKER_01]: profile sections of the wing and that's the limit so when you fly full tide with she at higher speed And you get unloaded, like usually we fly
[SPEAKER_01]: with 1G and turbulence more or less. But when you get unloaded, the twist has to stay there. So the glider will not... Sometimes it happens still
[SPEAKER_01]: with some gliders, they are older. The regulation is not there, not checked, or the people don't know. But I can tell, let's say, on takeoff,
[SPEAKER_01]: I can look at some high-performance glider. Okay, put on your VG, and I can see by the eyes how big is the war shot on the... standing because it's
[SPEAKER_01]: like a flying situation, complete weightless, let's say like this. So I can say if this glider is still safe on the safe side or not. Then
[SPEAKER_01]: sometimes I tell to explain to guys, listen, in certain situations, this is not so fun. This could be dangerous. Because what happened can be
[SPEAKER_01]: that you fly faster, let's say 60, 70, 80, you get unloaded, the twist goes down. It's like pushing forward on a sailplane and then it starts a
[SPEAKER_01]: negative loop and you cannot do anything because you get more and more weightless. And then you make, let's say, a high speed tumbling. Oh my
[SPEAKER_01]: God. This one you can avoid absolutely with the right design elements. So you can fly even in strong turbulence at higher speed and you have a
[SPEAKER_01]: stable, good, safe glide. So that's the thing that is very important, let's say like this. Otherwise, because even you could fly a glider
[SPEAKER_01]: without dive sticks and this tip limitation for the sail outside. But pretty much, even in bad conditions, just with one key of weight, you
[SPEAKER_01]: create that natural twist and the glider still flies, still is safe. Like the old Rogalo types, which they had no of this safety things. So
[SPEAKER_01]: over the years they understood the constructors, the manufacturers. But also, of course, then the certification that took care about this
[SPEAKER_01]: problem. So if you have a certified glider, the glider in this way is safe. But still, a hang glider, you can tamper every hang glider if you
[SPEAKER_01]: want. If you do something wrong in aerobatics or some stupid things, it's possible so that's still the it's very nice to fly the hang glider
[SPEAKER_01]: super nice but there's this limitation from the design and there's this limitation from the design the paraglider it still can collapse if the
[SPEAKER_01]: pilot is not aware and reacting quick enough so That's the limitation of the, they are super nice to fly, safe, I would say, but sometimes they
[SPEAKER_01]: have the limitation. When I fly the Swift, for example, or I don't fly a sailplane, you don't have these problems. You have other problems.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's say a plane, Without the engine, outlanding for them is a big problem, like in fields. So when there are people around, there was once
[SPEAKER_01]: we were joining the sailplane club. We had a bunch of people, hang gliders and sailplane pilots. So their stories was outlanding and our
[SPEAKER_01]: stories was like bad turbulence. Outlanding for us is not a problem. So everybody, every sport has their own problems. Indeed, indeed. I think
[SPEAKER_00]: we all have our poison of choice, which we love. But anyways, I think while we are talking about this, first of all, I should clear for my
[SPEAKER_00]: audience is Swift. When Manfred mentioned Swift, it's a hang glider. So if you Google up Swift hang glider, you will see the beauty of the machine
[SPEAKER_00]: that it is. It's a class two hang glider because we have like class one flexible. Class two is the hang glider. You still... have to be able to
[SPEAKER_01]: take off and land with your foot launch and foot landing in middle wind or nearly middle wind that's the definition and the rest is you can have
[SPEAKER_01]: aerodynamic control you can have span 20 meter span if you want so there's no limitation and and there you can really make the best high
[SPEAKER_01]: performance hang glider this way it's not you're not hanging you're sitting inside your your you're attached to the wing quite well so you
[SPEAKER_01]: don't move much so it's in in turbulence here it's very safe so i like it a lot to fly in strong conditions It's very relaxing compared to a hang
[SPEAKER_01]: glider in strong condition alone. When I fly alone, I want to enjoy a lot. When I was flying in competition and it was bad, I was not alone. There
[SPEAKER_01]: were many people around. So that's also a psychological factor which helps. If I would fly along in bad condition, I'm going to land. I don't
[SPEAKER_01]: enjoy that. But in competition, it's something else. So you have to be the combination guy. That doesn't matter. I'm not alone in this bad
[SPEAKER_01]: situation or in this turbulent. Quickly, while we're talking about this, Manfred, have you had a certain way of preparing yourself
[SPEAKER_00]: mentally or physically when you're navigating high risk, high reward situations like that? Let's say competing, it's rough. You have a whole
[SPEAKER_00]: tribe of pilots going out there and chasing glory. So how do you navigate high risk, high reward in terms of preparation with yourself over the
[SPEAKER_00]: past years? I think it's a lot of relating of your experience, of what you have gone through, what you have done and what you have experienced.
[SPEAKER_01]: There has been a situation where I said, okay, for me it's too much. I don't go back because sometimes in competition you go there, very bad
[SPEAKER_01]: place, very bad situation. Somehow you get out of it, you climb out again. come back and then you should go there again. It was a smaller
[SPEAKER_01]: competition. I went down landing. I went for the beer. I had fun. But funny that the local guy that years before He was quitting competition
[SPEAKER_01]: because for him it looked too much north wind, too much two-wheel land. So when you're on the ground and you see the situation, like in the Alps,
[SPEAKER_01]: you fly in the south side of the Alps and there's up there at higher level, there's north wind situation. And then higher cloud base, you can
[SPEAKER_01]: expect what's coming. This guy, he was young. He was a very good pilot. He was also in the national team. That was years ago. He dared to say it
[SPEAKER_01]: because when we rigged the glider, he was always looking up at the sky. I was watching him and he was like, not really. Let's set up the glider and
[SPEAKER_01]: get ready and let's start that competition. On a certain stage, he said, sorry guys, today I don't fly. And that was it. He never flew again. a
[SPEAKER_01]: competition outside of his club competition this region competition later i said for me it's too much but he knows the place better so he
[SPEAKER_01]: changed the other side of the well as soaring and then he did the course even in this bad condition and the girls down there they were like yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: so it was like he was still a good pilot but just competing on his that that was just i remember that this scene from this special guy which was a very
[SPEAKER_01]: good fellow young and he had somebody he had some when you are young and you think oh i can do everything yeah you feel the mental things is that
[SPEAKER_01]: much but then you have some bad experience in the air and then you think later oh shit that could have been worse and then of course that's in your
[SPEAKER_01]: head And then from experience, oh, today is probably not a good day to fly. And then you have to make a decision. I go for it or not. And then it's
[SPEAKER_01]: your personal decision, of course, if you say, no, for me, no, it's too much. It's today I don't fly, for example, of course. But I would say in
[SPEAKER_01]: competition and especially in good big competitions, the meat director or the people that decide the task, they look at the weather
[SPEAKER_01]: forecast, everything. So they try to protect their pilots. to make it safe and fun for everybody. Indeed. And I think one thing that comes to my
[SPEAKER_00]: mind is that a lot of us can depend upon the knowledge that is given to us by people who are making decisions for us in such a setting. But using
[SPEAKER_00]: strategies to make split-second decisions, let's say when you were out there, you tried going to this location which was not in your comfort
[SPEAKER_00]: zone, you came back and then going ahead there was again not worth the reward that you were getting. so staying calm and making a decision
[SPEAKER_00]: under these kind of situations do you recall any specific way that you've been handling this over a period of time and has it evolved as you
[SPEAKER_00]: have grown or as the technologies have had like how has this been a part of your flying career over the past years that you have grown as a pilot no i
[SPEAKER_00]: never have done specific i don't know programs or or whatever it's Also there, it's all in the experience you gained. And of course, sometimes
[SPEAKER_01]: to take risk, there are two different kinds of risk. The risk that you outland, you do bad. So risky decision during flight, you end up low and
[SPEAKER_01]: you don't get up anymore. It could work or sometimes it works to get at the better spot a little bit earlier, lower, that pays off. So that's one
[SPEAKER_01]: kind of, this is the risk. If it doesn't work, you're going to land and you're going to lose your competition or your championship or
[SPEAKER_01]: whatever. And the other risk is risking flying into areas where the landing possibilities are not good and you get hurt at the end. Having a
[SPEAKER_01]: bad landing or outlanding goes wrong and you messed it up completely and you cannot fly the next day. You are in hospital. So this one, this is, I
[SPEAKER_01]: think, the two biggest. And the other thing, of course, the risk of taking off in bad condition where you should not fly. When you fly alone,
[SPEAKER_01]: that's your own business then and you should know what you do. If everybody says, ah, today, maybe it's not good to fly, and you go up, fly,
[SPEAKER_01]: and then you have some consequences, like coming down with the parachute, that was not a good move. Indeed, indeed. But it is so hard to
[SPEAKER_00]: predict. A lot of times, I myself have personally found it hard to navigate where ground suck is a real one. People around you, or some
[SPEAKER_00]: people saying that, hey, No, no, no. When people around you say that, hey, you should not fly because it is outside their comfort zone. So they
[SPEAKER_00]: just tell you. And then those are the times you have to believe in yourself more and say that, sorry, I respect your opinion. Here you have
[SPEAKER_01]: to, especially when you are not flying so long, you should listen to the good guys. Not the guys that talk a lot, because they probably are not the
[SPEAKER_01]: best. You should know who is flying a lot, who has the experience, who is good, and you should more connect to these guys. In flying sites,
[SPEAKER_01]: there's the social side. People are coming together, have fun, and then they go flying. And there are also some sometimes more the competing
[SPEAKER_01]: side also from some guys. So they're pushing each other to make a little bit longer. And yeah, it's of course you have to learn and you have to gain
[SPEAKER_01]: experience and you can read many books if you want, but you have to to learn it on your own also. You can learn a lot, like theoretically
[SPEAKER_01]: reading a lot, also psychological things or whatever. But you have to be there and confront yourself with the situation and then make your
[SPEAKER_01]: decisions before flight or during flight. And also what is important after flight analyze your decisions and what you have done wrong so you
[SPEAKER_01]: learn all that's the important thing. Indeed. When you talk about identifying the kind of pilots whom to take advice from, as a new
[SPEAKER_00]: beginner, as we were talking just before the show began, that it's almost impossible to know because, first of all, you're taking baby
[SPEAKER_00]: steps in a brand new dimension that you've never entered as a human. Like, we're used to walking, we have a little bit of experience testing
[SPEAKER_00]: the waters with swimming, but flying... is something which overwhelms us so much in the first few hours that for someone who's giving us the
[SPEAKER_00]: advice and someone who's trying to keep us safe, at least when a student goes to the course and signs up with a teacher, it's like that teacher is
[SPEAKER_00]: inherently taking care of my life right now and he's making the decisions which will decide how safe I stay in this brand new dimension.
[SPEAKER_00]: Once you're outside the school, you're discovering the community on your own, you're going to social sites where people are just showing up,
[SPEAKER_00]: and then there are other places where people are competing and pushing each other. Identifying senior pilots with good advice, that is a very
[SPEAKER_00]: hard thing to navigate, and I do understand that there might not be a direct answer to this one. But how does one identify a good advice giver
[SPEAKER_00]: and a bad advice giver or somebody who just likes to brag? Because everybody loves gratification. I'm not going to hide this from the show
[SPEAKER_00]: right now. Everybody loves getting attention that, oh, my God, I've been flying. Even if they've been flying for 100 hours and they're
[SPEAKER_00]: flying for 10 years, like they've had 100 hours in 10 years, they will just love talking about and getting all the attention that comes with
[SPEAKER_00]: it. So as a new beginner, someone who's fascinated, you've done the hard work to reach the early 10 hours or 20 hour stage. How do you find the good
[SPEAKER_00]: ones, man? That's so hard to figure out. I don't know how. That's a good question. I think it's, of course, in the school, the beginning school
[SPEAKER_01]: was quite quick. It was like some flights and then you are free. Now you have to do much more high flights. So, of course, your instructor is
[SPEAKER_01]: First, it's the person you have to trust. Of course, there are good instructors, not so good instructors. And the instructor, they take it
[SPEAKER_01]: really serious and not so serious, let's say like this. That is something you will find out later. How was your instructor? That's the
[SPEAKER_01]: thing. But usually, I trust people and say that they try their best to give the knowledge to the students. And then, of course, after many
[SPEAKER_01]: flights, when they are free, It depends on the club, on the people that are there. There are people who say, oh, there's a new special in hang
[SPEAKER_01]: gliding. But we have a new student. Oh, yeah, welcome. So, of course, you help them. And I don't know how it is in paragliding because it's more
[SPEAKER_01]: industry, like teaching, making more students in some places. And I don't know. I don't know how it is in general. But I think to start... To
[SPEAKER_01]: get into a club where people are flying already for many years, you will find out quite quick who are the guys that are flying good regularly
[SPEAKER_01]: cross-country and always, let's say, on the safer side, never get hurt. If there's a guy around with some broken bones from time to time,
[SPEAKER_01]: probably it's not the right person to ask really good advice. Fair enough. What I wonder is that I think about this a lot because
[SPEAKER_00]: unfortunately or fortunately, I don't know, it has given me a fair bit of life experience. But learning this sport, I have come across some
[SPEAKER_00]: instructors which were absolutely magical to share knowledge. Top of the line, willing to give you all that they had and very easy to talk to.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then there are some instructors that I've come across which don't even know how to fly themselves in our teaching. I'm not kidding. For
[SPEAKER_00]: real that I have experienced. Yeah, I noticed also in hang gliding, it's still it's one thing is also age sometimes that they were flying years
[SPEAKER_01]: ago, a lot more. And like, like, The age comes and then, I don't know, they have some problems with their health. They're still teaching, but they
[SPEAKER_01]: cannot really show the students anymore how to do it correctly. They can tell them what to do, but the important thing is also that people, the
[SPEAKER_01]: students, get shown how it's done, how it should be. That's an important thing. And also in hang gliding, we have some instructors that don't fly
[SPEAKER_01]: anymore. And even when I started flying, My instructor at that time, she was a very good teacher to tell how to do it, but I never have seen her
[SPEAKER_01]: really flying. She was stopping flying already. And so I think that's, of course, that's not the best thing. The best thing would be that the
[SPEAKER_01]: teacher tells you and shows you how to do it. If I have to sum it up, do you think a person should just look for how passionate the teacher is about
[SPEAKER_00]: flying and not about money or not about filling the nine to five hours? Because passion does teach a lot and speak a lot about a person. So if you
[SPEAKER_00]: see a teacher still passionate about getting in the air and trying to learn himself. Of course, of course. It's about the passion. It's about
[SPEAKER_01]: the passion of flying. Yeah, it's of course that you have to see if that is your business, the money, the income. That's another thing. But the
[SPEAKER_01]: first part has to be the passion. And you can see before you enter school, you can get some information from other pilots that have done the school
[SPEAKER_01]: there and what's their thinking. But sometimes, especially in hang gliding, there are not many schools around. So you have to go there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, the next goal is 2-5-8. It's like this. When hang gliding, the school situation is quite bad. Paragliding is probably much
[SPEAKER_01]: better. You have a little bit more possibility to choose. I think that's for the very beginning. It's something, of course, people should find
[SPEAKER_01]: out beforehand. and not when it's a little bit too late or when they already started. And then they find out, oh, probably this school was
[SPEAKER_01]: not the best choice. But it's everything in life. First you trust and then at the end, it's like you have some workers on your house and they do a
[SPEAKER_01]: good job or a bad job. So, you know, you go to a mechanic and... Damn, that's a tough one. That's such a tough one indeed. But it's so true. You
[SPEAKER_00]: cannot know how good he'll fix your car until you actually get in the car. You can only tell after days, weeks or whatever, months, and you find out
[SPEAKER_01]: if they have done a good job or not. I think to sum it up, like having testimonials or reviews and everything, that is one way. But another
[SPEAKER_00]: way is to ask your instructor for his flight log or her flight log.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah. Show me how much time you spend in the air and how much time you spend on the ground, and then I'll decide whether you're worth going. This
[SPEAKER_00]: makes sense, Manfred, because as I was telling you, I think about this a lot. And when it comes to imparting education in real world, in other
[SPEAKER_00]: forms of human existence, Take any university lecturer, any high school person, anyone who is helping the younger generation grow or
[SPEAKER_00]: learn the craft. They have to write PhDs. They have to go through years of schooling on how to become an instructor. And in the art of free flight,
[SPEAKER_00]: we are letting people teach. with almost no experience. You don't have to pass any hard exams. You don't have to prove your skills. You just have
[SPEAKER_00]: to, like... I can speak about Norway because I live here, and the requirement to be an instructor is 60 flights in paragliding. And it
[SPEAKER_00]: shocks me beyond measure. 60 flights is a joke when it comes to learning the massive landscape that is there. And it's almost impossible to come
[SPEAKER_00]: to terms that... When it comes to being a teacher in every other aspect of human life, you have to go through insane amounts of research and
[SPEAKER_00]: training to be able to do that. And in this situation where the risk versus reward is literally life and death, You're just doing it without
[SPEAKER_00]: any supervision, without any legalities, without any kind of proper framework. And yet it's a growing sport. It's like people are spending
[SPEAKER_00]: money and making it happen in their lives. It's scary, to be honest, sometimes to look at. Oh, I agree. It's also that the person itself, that
[SPEAKER_01]: they are like... They want to give their experience. They want to teach. And the others, they want to fly and to do competition. And maybe later,
[SPEAKER_01]: they want to teach. I did also like 94, I think 30 years ago. I said in Austria in wintertime, I want to do a course, hang gliding teacher
[SPEAKER_01]: course. And already in Austria, 30 years ago, there's a hang gliding teacher. Nobody's asking for it. We do paragliding teacher. That's why
[SPEAKER_01]: I started paragliding was serious to get accepted because at that time it was already a minimum requirement experience. You have to show the
[SPEAKER_01]: commission that you're able to do certain maneuvers so that you get accepted. So at the end I became paragliding teacher and then later hang
[SPEAKER_01]: gliding teacher just doing something. But at the end I never really needed it because I'm not a teacher pilot. Maybe it's wrong. Probably I
[SPEAKER_01]: could be a good teacher as well with all my experience. Let's see in the future maybe. I was helping here now also here in Italy in Labeno to the
[SPEAKER_01]: flying side. We had a hang glider in school but now since many years not anymore and I was helping that was quite a fun. I liked it. Yeah. Let's try
[SPEAKER_00]: and address the elephant in the room from the other side, from the perspective of the instructors. It just crossed my mind. The first
[SPEAKER_00]: thing is, nobody likes to say that I'm a bad teacher or I'm a bad flyer. It's almost impossible to put it on yourself that, okay, I don't fly well
[SPEAKER_00]: or I don't know how to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Or even yourself. Nobody likes to tell, unless, as you said, you're competing, you can say that, okay, I'm a bad competition pilot yet, but
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm improving. So nobody likes to admit that. But one thing I think we can... Not everybody can win. That's the thing. There's only one person
[SPEAKER_01]: that can win a competition. Yeah. Of course, before other people win, I tell, okay, I win the competition again. Yeah. Yeah. But what I'm
[SPEAKER_00]: wondering is, should a person look back at themselves and say that, when can a person decide that they are ready to impart knowledge to the coming
[SPEAKER_00]: generation? Like, when should a pilot know that finally they have enough skills and experience that they are safe for the community when
[SPEAKER_00]: they go out there? It's always, even very good pilots still can learn a little bit here and there from other people just looking. And now with
[SPEAKER_01]: the internet and having good footage and videos available, you can learn already a lot there, which years ago was not possible. You could
[SPEAKER_01]: learn from theory, from book, or there was not much to look at it. You just can look at it at other pilots. And when you are at a very good level that
[SPEAKER_01]: you can say for yourself, I know how to do it, what's important, the technique I know, and I can teach that to younger people. But also, if you
[SPEAKER_01]: are not from one day to the other teacher, go to a school, help them find out what the teaching technique is, and you learn from them also. You
[SPEAKER_01]: have experience already when you went to the flying school, your flying school, and you learn. So you remember what they did and what was the
[SPEAKER_01]: procedure. how the teacher learns you so that that experience already you have when you're at the stage when you're a very good pilot and you
[SPEAKER_01]: want i think you also you have to be the person teacher person that wants to give the knowledge to younger people to new people again that's one
[SPEAKER_01]: thing but i don't know it's it's it's important that the teacher or the becoming teacher know how good they are they are still oh here's a weak
[SPEAKER_01]: point in this technique i have to improve that and to get a really good stage and you can then show the students how to do it and especially
[SPEAKER_01]: explain it also Makes sense. I know all the questions that I've asked you in the past one hour are not the easiest ones to answer, but I love your
[SPEAKER_00]: honesty. It's good to talk about it because usually we don't go too much in this direction of photography. talk about how was your flight and how
[SPEAKER_01]: was it there and here and that's it yeah but of course I have to remember when I started hang gliding how was it how you also have to as a long years
[SPEAKER_01]: flying experience pilot you have to get into imagination for the students they have no idea how to get back in their mind and start again
[SPEAKER_01]: it's not that easy because for you it's like a You do this and that. It's very easy. It's logical. It's normal. But for the beginner, it's a what?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, what is he talking about? They have to learn that. I totally resonate with that because I'll tell you what, I'm six years into flying
[SPEAKER_00]: almost 400 hours under the paraglider, which by no means, I'm not saying I'm a very experienced pilot. I'm still learning the craft. And when I am
[SPEAKER_00]: designing the shows for people like you and other people, I find it hard to go back to the beginner perspective that I was because my way of
[SPEAKER_00]: thinking was, was very different when I was starting the flight. And after all of these experiences, it changes a lot. So I think you touched
[SPEAKER_00]: upon a very important point there that if you want to impart knowledge to someone who's an absolute new beginner, try and put their shoes on and
[SPEAKER_00]: try and have their state of mind. Visualizing is absolutely not easy. That's just think back how when you started, what was your feelings?
[SPEAKER_01]: What was your problems, your fear? And how did you learn that? Yeah, I think that's important thing to get back to this stage when you started
[SPEAKER_01]: and so you can understand what the students, because students are not the same. The good one picks up quick and the other one takes longer. And
[SPEAKER_01]: probably there are some hopeless, but they are never hopeless. Even they have the chance, the right to learn and to become volunteers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Indeed. I think anybody who has entered the realm of flight is a blessed one out of these 7 billion on the planet. I think we are living in just
[SPEAKER_01]: exciting times, let's say like this, because to have this possibility, it's just not many years ago. Very true. There was no way to do it. Very
[SPEAKER_00]: true. Manfred, we are almost running out of time. But before on the closing section of storytelling, I quickly want to touch upon the
[SPEAKER_00]: technological aspect, because you are somebody who has seen these sports evolve from their very beginning. And three, four decades in the
[SPEAKER_00]: game, technologies have changed greatly. Although the competition is growing a lot in the manufacturer's market in paragliding, and hang
[SPEAKER_00]: gliding has been a little slow for various reasons. But Where do you see the technology going in time to come? Do you think technology is an
[SPEAKER_00]: essential factor in making it more safer, or is it just making it more expensive and the marketing is about safety? What's your take on this
[SPEAKER_00]: topic? A hang glider will be always a hang glider. Let's say the Class 1 or the paraglider will be pretty much always the paraglider. But
[SPEAKER_01]: especially in paragliding, there's been... big development from the beginning and then they fly amazing now and park and everything you put
[SPEAKER_01]: them in the cars and so it's it's really a great thing and now with this light materials you go up the mountain this is just a little weight and
[SPEAKER_01]: fly down there like the excel competition that's one example push to push that technology in this way still very good paragliders, but
[SPEAKER_01]: lightweight and safe also. And that's quite amazing, which direction that it went. And of course, when it comes to technology and material,
[SPEAKER_01]: single material, with the certification progress, there's also a load test required. So it has a certain minimum strength that's important.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you are sure that the glider will not break up in the air. but of course there have been people modifying things and putting them into danger
[SPEAKER_01]: and then just by doing stupid modification they cut them off the harness and they were like free falling it's also not good When you do some
[SPEAKER_01]: modification, you should ask some people with some knowledge what could be the consequences doing some modifications. That's
[SPEAKER_01]: especially for competition pilots. I think the average pilot that they are happy to get the material tested, good tested material, and they are
[SPEAKER_01]: fine, that they enjoy and that they will not do modifications. Modification thing is just for some few people, but they should know
[SPEAKER_01]: what to do. But of course, the safety standards there, I would say it's quite good. It's quite good. I would say that there's, of course,
[SPEAKER_01]: there's still a little problem with the designs, paraglider, hang glider, that they are not completely 100% safe gliders by their design.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the biggest part, I think it's the pilot. It's the pilot decision, pilot error. So I think the standards or material safety standards is
[SPEAKER_01]: quite high. It's quite high. It's also not possible for a manufacturer and they do a bad product and then they have problems. They have
[SPEAKER_01]: accidents because then it's a small world. It's the voice spreads out that week and oh, this guy doesn't do it or this equipment has some
[SPEAKER_01]: problems. So I think it's also in the favor. It's very important for the manufacturer to make things right. And what actually is possible with
[SPEAKER_01]: the technology without exceeding a certain cost. It's also a cost factor at the end. Do you guys have any visualizations for people like
[SPEAKER_00]: you who have seen the technology evolve since the beginning? And do you have any ideas how and where is it going? Like what next is coming up in the
[SPEAKER_00]: art of free flight for us as pilots and consumers? Yeah, that's interesting to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: The development will always go on. Even in competition, there are still little steps ahead. 20 years ago we said, the gliders are so good, it's so
[SPEAKER_01]: hard to make them better. But still, it's still possible. For competition, it's quite important to have drag reduction. It's just
[SPEAKER_01]: what creates drag. If you can minimize that, it gives you more performance. But I think that everybody that is doing serious
[SPEAKER_01]: competitions, manufacturers, they understand that they're going this way. When I started hang gliding competition, drag good airfoils,
[SPEAKER_01]: good harnesses, it was an option. But everybody had the same, pretty much the same. So it was little step by step. Oh, this one has done that
[SPEAKER_01]: here and there. So that's why he's gliding better or can glide faster. But that's in every sport where there's aerodynamic involved. If it's
[SPEAKER_01]: motorsport, sailplane, hang gliding, it's the same. The physics is there and that's the good thing. And from the material side, if material
[SPEAKER_01]: could be lighter again, it's already amazing the paragliders which light material they use and they fly good with all this technique inside
[SPEAKER_01]: the glider. Quite amazing to reduce also the lines. That's a good thing. And I think it will not stop. But as for a certain type of tank glider,
[SPEAKER_01]: paraglider, there will be a limit somewhere. And maybe we're already a little bit closer to the limits, but it's really possible to minimize
[SPEAKER_01]: things from the material and from the track. But I think it's still, you never say it's now, that's it. We cannot do it. That's bullshit. Wow. I
[SPEAKER_00]: think staying curious is the only way to find out. So time will tell. And I think on that note, Manfred, we have had a very holistic conversation on
[SPEAKER_00]: the topic of risk versus reward. I cannot thank you enough for being so open and honest about it. Thank you as well. yeah before we close manfred
[SPEAKER_00]: the best part of the show that is if you can share one flight one experience that comes to your mind that has stuck with you for your life
[SPEAKER_00]: from past decades of experience i think our audiences are very interested in that and because this has the highest listenership out of
[SPEAKER_00]: the whole episode so yeah i don't know which one that there are so many flights or so so many flights and experience and of course I think one
[SPEAKER_01]: good example is when I did the record flight 2001 with the hang glider, staying more than 10 hours in the air, doing really long, long flight,
[SPEAKER_01]: breaking the record landing and still being so fit. I could have flown for another four or five hours, just running out of daytime. That was
[SPEAKER_01]: very special. You will never forget. Even a long time ago when I was flying with some friends at my home place in Austria, it's just a hill for
[SPEAKER_01]: soaring mostly. And usually we have this, more and more to the south, there are bigger mountains. So there are also eagles. So when you fly
[SPEAKER_01]: there, sometimes you meet them, fly with the eagles. That's always something special. But it's very rare they are coming out to these
[SPEAKER_01]: foothills. And I had once this experience that at the end, it scared me. And it scared the bird a lot. Because I was soaring on a certain height.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was some good wind. Then below the bird coming, we have this smaller, like, buzzards, something. We have that in that area quite a
[SPEAKER_01]: lot. Okay. Not eagles. All right, so smaller eagles, let's say. Yeah, they're little. I don't know in German. And I was like, oh, here it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then he was coming up and wow, that's a big one. So at the end, that must be eagle. So it was a lonely guy, a lonely eagle that was just checking out
[SPEAKER_01]: the area, whatever. And I was just, he was just in front of me and lower. And I was in the back. So I said, okay, now I have the altitude and the glide
[SPEAKER_01]: path so I can come from behind. And so I come closer. And this eagle was just, I could see him like hanging there and looking around with the
[SPEAKER_01]: head, but he could not see me coming from the back. So at the end, I ended up, I don't know, two or three meters. And I got scared. This guy is not
[SPEAKER_01]: seeing me. What's going on? And what should I do? So I shout out a little bit. Hey! It just turned the head. When he saw me, he was just diving down
[SPEAKER_01]: like a bomb and never seen again. So I think this guy was scared at the moment. And I was also scared because I was so close. I was expecting
[SPEAKER_01]: that. But of course, they don't have natural hunters. So they should not be scared that someone attacks them. Yeah. very interesting this is the
[SPEAKER_01]: first i remember but there are so many there are so many situations so many nice flights enjoyable and it's landscape like the alps like high
[SPEAKER_01]: alps high mountains area where you never would go by feet or you never be there if you don't fly it so that's something really special yeah indeed
[SPEAKER_00]: i think but this is the first one of the one of the very few times i've heard a human spooking avian or aerial bird so i think you definitely got a
[SPEAKER_00]: special experience there but i think on that note manfred we have reached the limit of this episode heartfelt thanks for sharing
[SPEAKER_00]: everything so honestly and for taking out time for your super busy schedule with the coupe car coming up and all the excitement that is
[SPEAKER_00]: going in will you be there I hope I can. There's a lot to do with the podcast, but if I am, I'll definitely come by, say hi, and we'll talk more
[SPEAKER_00]: about sharing the art of flight and the joys that come with it. Maybe we have a beer. Sounds like a plan, Manfred. A beer with a pilot is always a
[SPEAKER_00]: blessing. Good. It was nice to share some thoughts with you and all the best for your show in the future. Thank you.